mrs. pence Charlotte thank you both for
being here
Charlotte I'd like to begin with you the
story behind the second pet starts in
Chicago when you were a film student at
DePaul University tell me about the
acquisition of the rabbit known as
Marlin yeah so Marlin like I am off
Craigslist for a student film project so
I was going to school at DePaul and I
wrote a short film and it needed a bunny
and so I asked the owner how much the
bunny costs and he said to make him an
offer and so it became its Godfather
joke with my friends and so we decided
to name Marlin after a Marlon Brando the
actor so his name is Marlon Bundy of
course now yeah obviously it had the
idea for the book come about yeah it
really came about started with Marlon
honestly he had a pretty popular
Instagram account and so we thought you
know it'd be really fun to do a
children's book about him and we thought
for the first one at least it should be
about the vice presidency because a lot
of people don't know a lot of details
and facts about the vice presidency I
know I didn't before my dad was vice
president so it was just a fun way to
tell the story through Marlins eyes and
mrs. pence you are an award-winning
watercolor painter tell me about doing
the illustrations for this this is a
collaboration that took a few months yes
it probably took about four months to
get all the watercolors done but it was
a lot of fun and Marlon is very good at
posing and we put him in a lot of
situations and he'll sit and wait till
we get just the right picture but
Charlotte and I did kind of collaborate
so we kind of say well for this stanza
what about if we do a picture like this
or like that and like when they go to
the Capitol Marlin is standing up
looking out the window of the car at the
Capitol so we we talked a lot about what
we wanted the pictures to be but I had
the privilege of actually getting to
paint them all what was that like
working together so much fun honestly
we've had a lot of fun and
we kind of started this whole project
way before I moved out so it was fun to
kind of be you know living long distance
and being able to call each other and
talk about the project or she would tell
me you know what painting she was
working on and send me pictures and send
me pictures of marlin all the time
and so we got to really work on it
together the whole time and what was
that like for you as a mother that is
watching your daughter grow up this is a
step out into the real world
tell me about what that was like for you
as a mother to be able to actually have
her sort of close as you worked on this
project and you know she I mean her her
degree was in filmmaking and writing and
she spent a year at Oxford learning how
to write and she's this amazing writer
in the family I knew that somewhere in
Charlotte's future was a book but you
know to have the privilege of
collaborating on her very first
published book was really an honor for
me it was a real treat Charlotte let me
ask you what kind of responses have you
gotten so far to this book Wow really
positive I mean it's it's been really
cool a lot of people just from Marlins
Instagram I think we're such big fans of
him that honestly a lot are not even
necessarily fans of our family who were
really involved in politics I mean
people will comment and say you know I
don't agree with your dad's politics but
I love Marlin and I can't wait for the
book so I mean it's been really positive
and it's been really exciting to see
that and Marlin has how many followers
on Instagram
he has like over 21,000 now and you post
on Marlins behalf oh yes yes you know he
dictates but then I I do have to ask
both of you because you know you
mentioned that there is obviously this
political climate now that is divisive
and as I know you're aware Charlotte
because you posted on this on social
media there have been some very sharp
criticisms with your book coming out for
instance the comedian John Oliver came
out with a parody book in which the main
character of the parody book is a rabbit
who is gay and I wonder what's your
response to that the criticism there is
obviously aimed at your fathers up
addition to same-sex marriage first of
all what's your response to that yeah
well I think that the post we put up
really summed it up I mean this was you
know always intended to be a fun book an
educational book and I mean it's a book
about a bunny a real bunny and so I
think it's really cool to kind of
actually see it be imitated but also
John Oliver's book I know is the
proceeds are going to charity as are a
portion of our proceeds and so it's kind
of fun I think we can have fun with it
and you know just see both of these
books gained some popularity and give
money to amazing charities it's a good
thing well I like what Marlon said on
his Instagram you know he said the only
thing better than one bunny book for
charity is two bunny books for charity
and so that's your official response to
that I think secondly by any objective
measure it is a difficult thing to be
the family member of someone who holds a
high-profile public office a publicly
elected official and I wonder how each
of you navigates that role Charlotte
what is that like yeah I think it's you
know it comes with the territory
certainly I mean my dad always talks
about how you know when we have
protesters I mean there have been
protesters outside our house you know in
the governor's residence now and he
always say you know Charlotte that's
what freedom looks like that's what
freedom sounds like and it's really true
I mean when people feel that they're
comfortable speaking up against their
elected leaders that's a good thing and
that's not the case in every country and
so I have to pair that with also being a
daughter and you know of course you
don't like seeing things especially
things that are untrue being said about
somebody that you love but I also really
grateful that we live in a country where
that can happen do you feel like
sometimes you wish you could push back
more or push back in a way that's kind
of more direct than you might otherwise
be able to maybe against the against the
untrue things that are said just because
I know my dad so well so I know when
things are being said that aren't true
but but then at
same time I think the way that I can
show my support really the best way is
just to support him you know and just to
talk with him about it and just you know
just be on his side and what about for
you mrs. plays how do you navigate them
well you know we we've raised our kids
to be free thinkers and to be
independent thinkers and you know all
throughout their growing up years and
still we'll have you know pretty
animated discussions about issues at the
dinner table and so I don't think it's
something that necessarily scares us
it's not like in our house everybody
believes everything that dad believes
you know it's it's not really like that
and you know if this has been over 20
years that we've been in politics so we
understand it it comes with the
territory you know that when you run for
office that people are going to express
their opinions I'm with Charlotte though
the only thing that bothers me is when
it's something that's not true but I
think when it's something that someone
honestly disagrees with someone who's an
elected official they should let their
voice be heard I'm also thinking of some
of the unfair credit criticism that has
been leveled at children oftentimes who
are still underage while they're say in
the white house during the Clinton's
time in office there was criticism of
Chelsea during President Bush's time in
office there was criticism leveled at
the first daughters and I wonder now
given what we have already seen so far
do either of you have an opinion because
it was you know not that long ago we
also saw some criticisms leveled at
Baron himself and I wonder as a mother
mrs. pence do you have thoughts though I
think probably everybody would say kids
should be off-limits you know yeah I
like what Chelsea Clinton says about it
I mean she says that they shouldn't be
clickbait um and she you know kind of
calls on the media to be better than
that and should not use kids to be
clickbait so I've always kind of liked
what she's the stance she's taken on it
let me go back to this idea of becoming
more prominent in the public sphere
because as you point out mrs. pence the
life of a public servant this is not
anything necessarily new for you and
your family but of course moving from
Indiana into the Naval Observatory at
washing in Washington is a much
different thing what does that
transition been like for you you know
it's really like the governorship on
steroids really I think that's a good
way to describe it I think probably the
hardest part is that there's so little
privacy you know we can't drive anywhere
anymore there's always a group of people
with us protecting us so that was a
little hard to get used to but then on
the other side at this level is humbling
to realize what an impression you make
when you go visit a Children's Hospital
or a school or military families
not so much anything special about Mike
and Karen pence but that this is the
second lady of the United States who is
coming to see our Hospital or our
program to be able to elevate some of
those people who need encouragement is a
privilege and it's a humbling thing as
well what about for you Charlotte seeing
them sort of make this transition from
Indiana to Washington DC yeah well I was
lucky because I got to go with them for
the first year back to DC so and I was
on the campaign trail so I really got to
see firsthand you know the transition
literally take place and so I feel like
we've we've gotten really close as a
family I've always been close but we've
definitely grown stronger and it's it's
just been fun to watch it's been fun to
watch you guys get into your new roles
and I know mrs. pence as a
lover of art you're someone who supports
the idea of art therapy tell me about
that mm-hmm
well actually I'm really glad you asked
that because Charla and I both decided
to choose a charity separately that a
portion of our proceeds would go to and
mine are the two art therapy programs
where I'm on the board one is Tracy's
kids which is for children with cancer
and the other is Riley Children's
Hospital their art therapy program and
what we're finding out about art therapy
is that it can actually help so much
with the healing process we see it a lot
with our veterans with PTSD that when
they go through art therapy or music
therapy programs that it actually
reprograms the brain and I've spoken
with soldiers who have said I was
suicidal and I don't go to that dark
place anymore
I've seen children with cancer who asked
their parents when can I go back to the
hospital and so there's something to
this art therapy program I'm not in our
therapist art therapy is done by someone
who has a masters or doctorate degree in
art therapy and it's amazing to watch
them work and Charlotte told me about
the charity that you've chosen yeah so I
chose to partner with a21 which stands
for abolishing human slavery in the 21st
century so they're an amazing
organization they spread awareness about
human trafficking they fight human
trafficking and they help survivors
kind of get back on their feet
afterwards so they have I think they
have offices really like 12 or 13
countries all over the world to in the
US and I've met a lot of their team
they're great and they also do a lot of
educational work to help people be able
to spot human trafficking in their
communities because actually it's a big
problem in the United States as well as
all over the world and I think they've
really had a lot of success with people
reporting human trafficking in their
communities since then
mrs. pence I want to ask you as a former
educator about just some things that
we're seeing in the news today obviously
school safety is a huge issue
there are going to be a number of
students from parkland who are heading
to Washington on Saturday for a March
and I wonder what your thoughts are on
that well you know honestly I feel like
as as second lady that no one elected me
or voted for me and so I hesitate to
talk policy just because I feel like
people would think well who does she
think she is telling us what she thinks
policy should be I mean we definitely
discuss a lot of these issues at home
but I mean we all want our schools to be
safe and so I'm also along with all the
other Americans looking to our elected
officials to say we need to do something
to keep our children safe in school
that's in one place they should be safe
Charlotte do you have any thoughts on
that
these young people coming from parkland
from other schools as well that are
planning to come and just express their
thoughts on this any you have any kind
of feeling about that to see young
people coming to the nation's capital E
yeah I think it's just what my mom said
honestly I mean I think everyone wants
to you know see this violence stop and a
light I mean like I said before I mean
that's what freedom looks like and I
think it's I think it's it's great for
anybody to voice their opinions and to
you know take advantage of our rights to
gather and and to protest to speak out
what surprised you about being in
Washington so far is there anything that
you can think of off the top of your
head was it what you thought it would be
was it perhaps not all you thought it
would be I don't know I think I think
about it it's kind of funny since we're
still in it I think we'll look back on
things and I'll be able to tell you that
what surprised me or not but our family
is again kind of remained unchanged in a
way I mean we're kind of this unit and
we were before and we will be after you
know and this is just a role that we
have right now
and I think you know for us I think one
of the advantages is that when Mike was
in Congress the kids went to school in
Northern Virginia and that's where I
taught so we have a lot of friends who
have known us for a long time it's nice
to have those friends who knew us before
this role came along the kids all have
friends so when they come back and visit
they're like you know I'm going out with
my friends tonight or we're gonna have
all the friends come over so we have
that advantage of having a community
already in Washington so that was a big
benefit for us turning back to the book
tell me a little bit about what people
will learn about this role of
vice-president from Marlin Bund oh yeah
so that was a big part of the book
really was that it's supposed to be fun
nonpartisan and it's educational so we
wanted to teach kids adults and teachers
about the role of vice presidency I
think specifically we talked about how
their naval enlisted aides that work at
the Naval Observatory which I didn't
know that kind of take care of the house
and then he goes and works at the eeob
which Marlin talks about which is where
his ceremonial offices Eisenhower
executive office building and and he is
the president of the Senate so he can
cast a vote in the Senate and he can
what else the fact that we live at the
Naval Observatory so it's actually
working observatory yeah I know the Vice
President had students from Washington
DC come and watch the Eclipse there so
we've gotten the benefit of being able
to go over and look through the
telescope at night of the stars and so
there are some interesting things that
people might not realize about the role
of the Vice President so Charla said
let's tie all these together and have
Marlin go to all these things in one day
so that's what the book is and has
Marlin boon to the White House
he has been to the eeob the Eisenhower
executive office building he went and
met with the military families there so
he's been there he's not he goes to the
Oval Office in the book but
in real life he's not not yet for an
invitation yeah I think he has some
connections what is it that you think
people misunderstand about the role of
the Vice Presidency or misunderstand
about the current vice president mm-hmm
I think that I think it's such an
ambiguous role so I think it since it's
defined by the president for every
administration and really probably every
term it's it changes all the time so I
don't know if people are
misunderstanding or if they just don't
really know you know with the what the
vice president does like I didn't so in
the book at school it's we kind of
talked about my dad specifically as well
and what his day actually kind of looks
like so people will learn a little bit
about the vice presidency and also about
my pets and what do you think mrs. fence
are there are things that people
misunderstand either about the office of
the vice presidency itself or that they
misunderstand about your husband the
vice president well I think Charlotte's
right I think every vice president has
kind of done their own thing and it
really does depend on the president and
what he wants that vice president to do
at the Naval Observatory every vice
presidential family has left their mark
on the home in a certain way and one of
those we talked about in the fax at the
back of the book is what the Biden's did
when when they left one thing that they
left for the house so it's it's kind of
this little tradition that just kind of
got started that everybody leaves
something at the house one thing that
we've done is we've brought the Beehive
so we also now have over 30,000 bees who
reside at the vice president's home and
so their honey producing these yes honey
well we're hoping to get a harvest soon
we haven't gotten a harvest yet but
we've got our little bears ready to go
as soon as as soon as we're told we can
harvest we don't want to take any out
that they need so it's all the excess
honey as well yeah or not
they're in the beekeeping suit I take it
that we have someone who does it very
very daunting task what else do you
think people need to understand you are
actually there and occupying a place
that very few people will ever see and I
wonder what it is not just the physical
space itself but the role itself you
think that will help people understand
what it's really like to be the vice
president what it's really like to be
the family of the vice president yeah I
mean I think I mean I think well like I
was kind of saying before you know we
won't always be in this role and so I
think that's always an important thing
to remember to kind of take advantage of
it at the time have fun with it you know
keep communicating with one another and
staying close and yeah I think that's
that's what I would say I mean I think
it's um it's like Charlotte said it's
we're only there for a short time and so
while we're there we want to do what we
can to help people as much as we can and
I think maybe that's something that
maybe we didn't understand coming into
it what what it would mean because you
sort of feel like well I'm just caring
pence what can I do but knowing that if
I get behind an issue it does elevate it
if I step up and encourage people it
does mean a lot if we have military
families come to the house swim in the
pool which we've done it means a lot to
them and so I think trying to take
advantage of all of those opportunities
is is something we really work hard at
final question then given what you just
spelled out in this platform that you
both have what's next
hmm well you know what next for me is
I'm gonna start focusing a lot more on
military spouses I feel like our
military spouses they serve as well and
it's tough for them they have a tough
road it's difficult to move every two
years get the kids in school find a new
job
and so we're going to do what we can to
kind of come
side them for you Charlotte yeah I mean
I'm I think I'm always gonna be a
storyteller so writing or making films
working in an entertainment it's
definitely something that I see myself
doing alright Karen pens Charlotte pence
thank you both so much really thank you